former Newcastle and Everton footballer
Christian atsu has been found dead in
Turkey Following last week's earthquakes
well joining me now has gone in sports
journalist awuraku on pofo and I do
express my apologies if I've
mispronounced that but thank you so much
for for joining us
um just your reaction to this news and
can you explain to our audience just
just how much of a big loss this is for
Ghanaian football
well it's it's been very difficult to
take one that perhaps a lot of people
could say that they could see it coming
but it has really been you know an
emotional roller coaster not just for me
but for a number of ghanaians who I
thought that they had witnessed a
miracle uh in the early hours of Tuesday
just about 26 hours after it was
reported that Christianity uh had been
you know put under the rubble by the
earthquake and the news that we go on
Tuesday was that he had been rescued and
a lot of people were addressed and
thought that you know there's finally
been some good news after a very
difficult 26 hours but there were
reports just the day after that the club
uh you know did photo with that and
retracted the information because there
was a possibility of a mistaken identity
and so once again ghanaians went from
100 straight to zero and it was just a
matter of Hope now as the hours passed
by but it's been more than a week and
finally there's been the news that he's
passed away uh a lot of ghanaians still
held on to hope that he could be still
found alive you know from the
information from the agent that due to
the scans that had been taken on the
body there were still some lives under
the building that he stayed but
unfortunately he didn't come out alive
and so it's been a very bad start to the
weekend for a lot of ghanaians it's been
very quiet in town people are really sad
Christian are true he's one of the
players that love people who dearly not
just for the football that he plays but
also for the community work that he's
been putting in
yeah I was going to ask you about that
he sounds like not just an incredible
footballer but an incredible human being
um Christian Natsu of course was likened
to Lionel Messi in Ghana but also did a
lot of charity work so what what's the
reaction been to this news Across the
Nation
or just just on the messy bit I remember
in an interview with BBC sport uh after
he scored his second goal in two games
against Malawi in an Africa Cup of
Nations qualifier he was asked that he's
been compared to you know Lionel Messi
what does he think about that and he was
like no no no he there's no Guardian
Messi and uh there would never be
another messy and he cannot even do up
to one percent of what mess he's doing
it's impossible and he said that you
know smiling and laughing because he's
always been a messy guy and he's always
looked up to him and so I think that
interview defined who actually was he
was very humble very jovial and most
importantly he always wanted to put a
smile on the faces of people he was
asked about his charity wreck and he
broke down in tears that whenever he's
driving around in Ghana and he sees
children you know begging on the street
his heart aches and that's one thing
that he wants to put the stop to and so
he's always been actively involved in
donations uh he's done an ambassador for
arms around a child as an organization
that helps children you know provide
orphans with you know basic you know
amenities like clothes homes and
education and it's not just about
children as well he's been actively
involved in the prison whack here in
Ghana uh with his passion for prisons he
was connected to the crime check
Foundation uh through you know in a way
where he could reach them behind bars
and actually was a strong advocate for
the passage of the non-cons custodial
you know sentencing bill which was
passed here in Ghana into law and so
essentially uh not every crime amend
that you do jail time there was an
introduction of you know community
service or that the probation order and
you know supervision all that amongst
others he's also helped various
prisoners one that comes to mind is a 62
year old lady who avoided a tenure in
prison now actually paid for the release
of this woman she was affectionately
known as Mama Teresa now she was
sentenced 10 years to jail for
possessing Mariana but you know the
former Chelsea style intervened and paid
for a fine and she avoided prison and so
there are a number of other stories you
know other prisoners who shared their
stories that when they come out of
prison actually helps them in terms of
setting up a business for them a startup
to ensure that they have a livelihood so
that they do not return to prison as
well so he's been very influential off
the pitch in Ghana I think that that's
why I had a lot more because a lot of
people depend on actually not just as
family members so it's still going to be
the same world but I think in the end
it's going to be a bit emptier because
we're not going to have a wonderful Soul
like Christianity around
and I hope I've said that correctly we
really appreciate appreciate you joining
us uh today and our condolences over
Christian atsu thank you so much for
speaking to us
thank you too